this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week we've got a double feature for you
as we take a pleasant dive down to the
iconic vistas of rapture in Bioshock 1
and 2. don't try this at home kids uh
definitely don't try it at home don't
try underwater either let us know other
games or guns you'd like to see Jonathan
break down and be sure to subscribe for
more Firearms expert reacts as we'll be
covering BioShock Infinite as well as
new videos coming soon covering the
saber Duels of Star Wars Jedi Survivor
and much much more right over to
Jonathan
right this revolver is pretty clearly
based on the Webley series it's the size
and proportions of the Mark VI it's not
quite right though The Recoil Shield at
the rear of the cylinder is is too in
closing if that makes sense and that is
directly in your field of view from the
first person view whereas from the side
it looks a pretty good approximation of
a Weebly of course this is not I don't
think our universe I remember rightly
and so we have a lot of license there
for things looking different anyway so
I've taken some license and the example
I've grabbed from The Collection is not
in fact a Webley Mark 6 at all it isn't
even the side Stirrup latch system at
all this is the Webley price system
which is a pinch
to break so it's still break open and
the reason I've shown it to you is it
kind of belongs in a video game so
although the revolver in this game is
actually very plain this is beautifully
sort of blue until it's almost Black
Mirror finish and then gold decoration
all over it it's just it's beautiful I
think I know it's not steampunk but the
word steampunk still inevitably Springs
to mind looking at that kind of thing I
don't know if it's the decoration or the
slightly Antiquated look at the thing
but it almost looks like it might be
firing something other than just
ordinary bullets um even though it
doesn't
thank you
trouble with revolvers in video games if
you want an upgrade system how do you
increase the size of a say a six shot
cylinder well you can't you genuinely
there's nothing you can do about it
you've kind of got to build it a
building a revolver design that allows
you to put a fit a bigger cylinder if
you want to do it realistically or maybe
a like the chain pistol something where
you can bolt on capacity and bolt-on
capacity is what they've done but
they've done it in a way that I can't
think of a way of it working one way you
could make it work is like the revolver
feed on the original dushka machine gun
recent forgotten weapons video on that
one we have one as well so you have a
revolver feed but a belt going into it
that would be one way to do it here it
really just doesn't make any sense it's
kind of just fudged on
no this is a hyper stylized Thompson
submachine gun stylized to the point
that it doesn't really in detail look
anything like a Thompson this is a model
1928 with a drum from one of our model
1921s
just for effect
you may have Glimpse this in a recent
thumbnail I went with the 28 because our
21s don't have Cuts compensators and
this game model is trying to represent
the cuts compensator on the end to try
to control recoil the general silhouette
is about right and that's all most
people gonna care about all the detail
is is incorrect the cocking handle is on
the side more like an M1 but it does
still have a slot in the top
nonetheless which is interesting and
actually the drum on this gun is clearly
meant to be the 50 rounder because it's
substantially smaller than this dinner
plate in front of me oh the rear sights
on this thing are
a bit of a weird extrapolation I suppose
of what's on the real gun which with the
model 21 Model 28 you have these big
steel protectors that's correct although
they're a bit too beefy on the model and
then there is a when folded flat there's
a not very good little combat Notch
there not great for a submachine gun by
any means
that's because you flip up the whole
thing and you have a highly adjustable
very long range rear sight there
adjustable out to 600 yards
but in any case I think you'd want to
flip it up on its minimum setting and
use that aperture there for aiming so
the site on the real gun is also not
great not when folded flat but it
doesn't look like the one in the game
with that weird spindly
rear Notch that's right at the rear of
the protectors we have cocking's handle
slots on both sides cocking handles on
both sides cartridge cases are ejecting
from the left of the gun kind of
irrespective of where the clocking
handle is
when the thing's cocked it's to the rear
which it ought to be on an open bolt gun
but then when you attach the magazine
the bolt closes itself it's all very
fudged um I know the the Bioshock games
are so good and well loved I I feel bad
criticizing their guns but they are not
very realistic from what I've seen so
far
he was a club
so I actually think this this sort of
pimped version of the Thompson gun is
more like it strangely because of the
setting of The Game there's a diesel
Punk Shenanigans when the gun's all
tricked out with the glowing bits and
the cables and the extra gubbins it sort
of rounds out the design and it looks
better
um I wonder if it was designed as a sort
of modified concept gun first and then
retrofitted to a bear gun if you see
what I mean because that would explain
why it's so skinny and odd looking when
it doesn't have its attachments that's
just a speculation on my part but if you
took a normal 28 model Thompson and then
attached all of this to it it would be
hugely bulky and it might look a bit
weird on screen so that would that would
be one reason why they've taken artistic
license with the bass Thompson gun
all right
this is very cool actually this is the
Spencer or Spencer Roper system shotgun
um you can although while some other
early pump action guns have a dinky
little pump grip like this as well but
if you see that and some two Massive
Action bars
and especially the way they connect to
the frame here with this this rounder
shape here and then this distinctive
bolt on the top that drops down
well then you're looking at a Spencer so
this is the model 1882 so it's a great
choice for a retro looking pump action
of course we then massively trick it out
for the game with some modifications
that don't necessarily make logical
sense but that's fine this is a fantasy
game Above All Else we've got electric
ammunition seeing that in other in other
games as well of course delivering a
different form of damage or enhancing
the damage somehow with electricity and
then the modified version I've just been
looking at with there was a joke in the
steampunk Community about gluing some
gears on it and calling it steampunk
well that's almost we've stuck some cogs
in it and called it diesel punk I think
the cogs are meant to somehow enhance
the rate of fire how they would do that
well they wouldn't would they exposed
Gear wheels
embedded in the action of your shotgun
means that something is going to stop
working in your Shotgun but it does look
quite cool as an upgrade
thank you
all right this is an interesting one
this is a grenade launcher obviously
some sort of belt or or multi-shot feed
device on the side and it's not exactly
homemade but it is what we would call
craft produced I.E produced in a
workshop or a very small Factory perhaps
using some improvised components this
notably has a receiver I think it is
that is labeled condensed milk so it's
been it's been made from tins of
something oddly substantial tins of
something I will say because there's no
way a tin can is going to contain the
pressure of firing any kind of
projectile so no don't try this at home
kids uh definitely don't try it at home
don't try underwater either but it's a
very cool concept for a weapon I think
the I'm a bit confused by the the reload
on this where we're twisting the whole
weapon apart and then attaching it and
that is that is feeding in new rounds
that the feed device would seem to be
separate from the receiver from the
barrel unit I'm not it's not clear how
that actually attaches together or how
it relates to the magazine feed system
so it's I think it's another fudge
design but it looks coherent and it
seems like it might work if you don't
look too closely which is all you need
this is quite unusual
blame thrower except that it does other
effects as well or delivers other
effects as well flamethrower mode is I
won't say typical because it's it does
have a different sort of flavor to it if
I can run it that way then we have
liquid nitrogen doing the same thing
from the same gun only it's ammunition
dependent as to whether it's flame
or ice of course living things would
suffer pretty badly from being frozen
solid but we don't worry about that in
this case and as if two types of
throwing wasn't enough there's also an
electric gel attachment as well so
that's essentially turning it into a
sort of cattle prod so it's three
weapons in one I don't remember seeing
anything quite like this before like a
lot of the other weapons in the game
looks looks good feels good not sure it
stands up to Too Much scrutiny uh we're
attaching our
um fuel or whatever type to this to us
to the side with a valve that doesn't
seem to then get closed to attach it so
that seems to be slightly glossed over
now again it makes sort of intuitive
sense that you're attaching something or
slapping something then it works it's
just that if you think about it it
doesn't seem to make too much sense
I'm afraid I can't begin to work out how
this rivet gun works it's obviously a
take on the the classic nail gun we
think tend to think of quake Don't We
for for that um or I do and I suppose I
didn't question it at the time um this
one has additional moving Parts the the
railway or the locomotive style rod and
wheel on this on top I've just forgotten
what they're called I'm sure train
enthusiasts and comments will remind me
um looks really cool I'm not really sure
how the heck that would help buy a
rivets or shoot rivets at things it does
sort of feel right for the game though
to have that weapon in the game and for
it to work in the way that it does not
too much to say about that except that
we have an automatic ejecting magazine
or ammunition container which is
actually something we're going to cover
on the Royal armories Channel
in the not too distant future so keep an
eye out for that
[Music]
sonoff shotgun uh quite uh well it's
hard to see in first person view but
having seen it from the side this thing
has actually relatively long barrels for
a sworn off taking a sort of firearm is
never never a good idea
um almost never nice to have a sawn off
though in the game it does somehow seem
to make sense and the
stylistic changes
bring it in line with the look of the
game so if this was just a Mad Max style
sonoff shotgun or even an old west coach
gun with absolutely nothing different
about it it might not fit so well but um
we have got some additional pieces on
here I couldn't tell you what they what
they do or how they work I don't think
this has been referenced off a real side
by side sworn off the proportions of
everything are are weird sort of
exaggerated proportions really the
sights are well a not really the sort of
sites you have typically have on a
shotgun anyway and B
two rare sites
um there's not a shotgun would typically
have just a bead a Sono shotgun would
have no sight on the front unless you
welded one back on or something because
it's been cut down this has two little
shallow notches one at the front one at
the back doesn't make any sense for a
sight probably better than no sight at
all depending on how they're set up but
you're not ideal because you won't be
able to align them very efficiently now
the ammunition type here phosphorus buck
shots dragon's breath is a real shotgun
round and in fact there is a dragon's
breath Buckshot round as well that
contains actual projectiles and doesn't
just attempt to set things on fire I'm
not sure that the dragon's breath
Buckshot existed when this game was
first made I could be wrong it'd be
quite entertaining if the game had
anticipated something that then happened
in real life normal dragon's breath with
the incendiary effect has been around
for a lot longer than the game
oh
[Music]
now this is more like it so I think the
additional bits that are attached to the
shotgun when I first saw it are brackets
for attaching upgrades some sort of
Tesla looking or Nixie tube type valve
type things on the side I'm not quite
sure what they're doing different
ammunition types incendiary ammunition
normal Buckshot probably something else
and then what they've done for the
capacity upgrades makes sort of more
sense than the revolver does yeah we
have independent revolver cylinders of
three rounds that have been inserted so
the breaches of the barrels have been
chopped away the standing breaches of
the action are still there and then we
have revolving cylinders one for each
Barrel so we already have revolving
shotguns so it's not a problem to have
rotating Chambers with cartridges in
them that align with the barrel and have
the breach at the rear with the firing
pin to fire the cartridge and so you
could you could probably make a version
of this that would function I don't know
how it would automatically revolve the
cylinders and I said suddenly don't know
how it would reload most plausibly I
suppose you would replace this you'd
have replaceable cylinders somehow and
yeah it all sort of falls apart when you
when you get into the detail of it but
it has an upgrade to a fantasy shotgun I
like it
foreign
obligatory Gatling gun nothing wrong
with that one-handed especially in some
sort of 50 caliber cartridge type this
looks to be again craft produced lots of
flat angles sheet metal metal plates
metal tubes and some weird broken off
Rusty looking circular thing on the top
I've got much else to say about that one
to be honest
um no obvious way of aiming this thing
there's something on top of the gun but
there's no no functional sights that I
can see and in fact the way the way it
has you have to hold it there'd be no
obvious way of aiming it this is sort of
an Aiming technique as well in real life
in certain situations and certain times
of in the past you simply look where
your shots are going and adjust
accordingly of course in the game you
have a permanent reticle in the middle
of the screen anyway so that's not
really a problem
thank you
this is a cool weapon I think I can
safely say
industrial diesel Punky designers most
of the guns in the game are this isn't a
gun though this is a harpoon or spear
gun it's got some sort of motor for
drawing back the mechanism to store up
the energy to then release it somehow
not quite clear how it's working but it
seems to make sense like some of these
other weapons not sure what the spinning
uh gear or wheel is near the muzzle of
this thing if you could call it a muzzle
the really interesting part is the Trap
ammo uh I see so the the Trap Spears are
not trailing a cable they are magically
projecting one after they've hit their
target which makes a bit less sense but
I'm sure has a valid gameplay reason
[Music]
speak
and a fairly conventional if I can use
that word for it for this game which I
feel like I can't uh grenade launcher
distinctive design very industrial
feeling sounding awful lot of recoil
built in although a number of the
weapons do have perhaps excessive recoil
the revolver is is very
Snappy seeming but this thing launching
essentially a bomb yeah it's going to
have a decent amount of recoil they had
to develop a special type of ammunition
to allow an actual shoulder-fired
grenade launcher prior to that you were
bracing the butt of your rifle with
grenade launcher on it into the ground
in various ways otherwise the recall
would very likely break your shoulder so
a projectile of that size and mass is
yeah you need some way of managing The
Recoil the game doesn't worry about that
it just but it does show you that you
are chucking something with a
significant amount of mass and indeed
explosive potential that's it that's the
guns of Bioshock one and two
um hopefully we'll come back and do
infinite because that's the only one
I've actually played all the way through
but I very much enjoyed taking a look uh
very distinctive art style for those
games really really good to to watch as
always you can check out what we do here
at the Royal armories over on our
website our social media accounts you
can also head over to our YouTube
channel for more gun nonsense from me
thanks guys we'll see you next week